- The reason Taiwan knew about this was
because there were Taiwanese doctors
who had heard from their
mainland colleagues
that the medical staff in
Wuhan were getting sick.
So that's how you know
human-to-human transmission
is occurring, it's when
it's not animal-to-person,
but person-to-person, the patients
are transferring it to the doctors.
So Taiwan reports this
and it takes weeks before,
I think on the 14th of January,
you still have that
famous tweet by the WHO
saying there's still no evidence
of human-to-human transmission.
Two weeks after Taiwan
told them that there was.
(serious music)
- Hey, I'm Dave Rubin and
this is "The Rubin Report".
Reminder everybody, you can get all
of our full episodes absolutely ad free
five full days early at rubinreport.com.
And, more importantly, joining me today
is the Managing Director
of Ideas Beyond Borders,
as well as the New York
Editor for Spectator Magazine,
Melissa Chen, welcome
to "The Rubin Report".
- Hi Dave, thank you for having me.
- I cannot believe that this is your
first solo appearance
on "The Rubin Report".
You were on the show way back
when, when we were on Aura TV.
That's something like
20-25 years ago, I think,
at this point, with our
friend Faisal Al Mutar,
who's your cohort at Ideas Beyond Borders.
- Yes.
- There's a ton I wanna
talk to you about of course,
but can you just very
quickly, who is Melissa Chen?
How did you get to "The Rubin Report"?
- Well I have to thank
you for having me on again
because that last time,
when I did it with Faisal,
I had the worst hair possible.
I was, for some reason,
identifying as a male K-pop star
and I don't know what was going on.
So I'm thankful to have
another chance to show
what it actually can
look like, potentially.
So my name is Melissa.
- Yes, your hair's
looking very luxurious by the way.
- Which is hard to do when
there's no barbers, okay?
So I'll put that out there.
So my name's Melissa and I
now also am a journalist,
I write for "Spectator",
which is a British magazine.
And I also run a nonprofit organization
called Ideas Beyond Borders,
together with Faisal Al
Mutar, who's a dear friend
of both me and Dave's for a long time.
I grew up in Singapore.
So I only came to the
U.S. when I was about 17,
came for college.
Loved the experience of living in a place
with so much civil liberties.
And I guess I stayed after college.
I have actually a background
in computational biology,
that was my degree and, like
a good Asian or a bad Asian,
I guess, I'm not using my degree
and I ended up running
a nonprofit and writing.
So that's how I got here.
- Yeah, all right, very good.
Let's just quickly
recap a little bit about
what you guys are doing
with Ideas Beyond Borders
and then I wanna focus more
on what you've been doing
related to Coronavirus,
some interesting stuff
in New York City trying
to get people supplies
and you have some knowledge
on what's going on
with China and the rest of it.
But just tell everybody a little bit
about Ideas Beyond Borders.
Because before Corona, there
was a whole other world
out there and you guys were doing
some really great stuff
and continue to do.
- Right, I mean it's interesting
because early January of 2020,
the focus of this world
was on the Middle East,
right after the whole General
Soleimani was killed in Iran
and that was shifting the focus
to that part of the world.
It seemed like a hotspot.
There were protests going
on in Lebanon and Iraq
and so that seemed like
it would be the start
of World War III or something
and then all of a sudden Coronavirus,
it just consumed everything.
So Ideas Beyond Borders is
a nonprofit organization
founded by my friend Faisal,
who is an Iraqi refugee.
And what we do is we take ideas
that are not available in Arabic,
translate them into the language,
and make them freely available.
We focus on ideas about
science, about philosophy,
and about civil rights, pro
liberty ideas basically.
And the idea is just if
you have a heteronormative,
heteronormative? Sorry, heterodox.
If you're exposed to heterodox ideas,
that it would challenge peoples' minds
and it would open up dogmatic thinking.
So that was the reason Ideas
Beyond Borders was founded.
And actually today, not only
have we done a ton of books,
Wikipedia articles, we've also done videos
and right now we're actually combating
a lot of the misinformation
about Coronavirus in Arabic.
Because ever since China
released that whole
propaganda theory about the thing about
the US army was the one
that released the virus,
that's the kind of conspiracy theories
that take root in the Arab world,
that's what they wanna believe.
Yeah, all right, so we're
obviously gonna focus
a lot on that but, very quickly,
you mentioned that you
grew up in Singapore
until you were 16, 17 years old.
Can you just talk a little
bit about what that was like
and why that kinda led
you to being someone
that actually cares about
freedom of expression
and open inquiry and all that good liberty
stuff that you talk about?
- I mean, Singapore's a
great place to grow up.
In a way, it's very stable,
very safe and very affluent
as a country, very, very
high GDP per capita.
But the one thing that we didn't have
was political freedoms.
So Singapore's ranked pretty low in terms
of freedom of the press, freedom of speech
and also very basic things,
like there is absolutely
no freedom to assemble.
So if you decided to
go into a public square
and hold a sign that said
something like, I don't know,
"Impeach the Prime Minister"
or something, or even just
"Against the Death Penalty",
you would be arrested
because you didn't get a
permit for the protest.
And that's the kind of
very ordered society
that it has created.
But for me it's always
kind of been this thing
on my shoulder, kind
of weighed down on me,
that you couldn't just speak your mind,
you always had to censor
and I knew I wanted
to be in a place where
this was just not even,
I didn't have to think about,
that you could just be free,
be free to be yourself, so that's why I
chose the United States.
- Yeah, how are we doing
with that in America these days?
- (laughs) You know
what? Still a lot better.
But it's heartbreaking to hear and see
that these freedoms
are slowly being eroded
and really we were doing it to ourselves.
And it may not be coming
from the governments
but when you have this kind of mob rule
and cancel culture, it
is a defacto censorship
and it ends up having similar
effects on your psyche,
on society as a whole
and it kinda bubbles up.
But it's still very different,
I would have to say.
There's a difference
between getting disappeared
by your government and getting
jailed by your government
for saying the wrong thing
than it is lose your job but still sucks.
- Yeah, for sure.
So let's talk a bit about corona and China
and some of the things
that you've been doing.
So, first I wanna start, you
had a tweet thread recently
that you found a donor who wanted to put
a whole bunch of money to get
doctors and nurses
- He was a donor
of my organization.
- Yeah, and he wanted to put money
in so the doctors and
nurses could get masks.
That's sort of the short version of it
and suddenly you found
out that there is a lot
of red tape to make what should be
simple things happen actually happen.
- Right, right, so this what they call
personal protective
equipment, short would be PPE,
it includes masks, gowns, the face shields
and everything that healthcare workers
really need to use to protect themselves
and a lot of people had been talking about
okay, we're in dire need of
this, we didn't stockpile,
a lot of the hospitals didn't stockpile,
the states didn't do it.
And so when you have
a sudden rush of cases
as you did in New York City,
the ICUs were over-capacitated,
that's when hospitals realize that,
oh no, we're running out
of PPEs very quickly,
we're just going through
them at such a quick rate,
and it was a huge shortage.
And it's not just in the United States,
it's pretty much anywhere else.
Italy's facing the same problem as well.
So a very, very kind donor reached out
and said, "I really wanna help."
And he's not the only one.
There are a lot of people that,
it's one of the best things about America,
is this ingenuity from just average people
who when there's a
problem, they just step up
and wanna just contribute somehow.
And so what I started finding was,
okay, I got the hospital saying
we need the PPE so badly,
healthcare workers are
saying the same thing
and then donors are coming forward.
But then to even make that match happen
and get the masks to the
people that need them
was a complete Kafkaesque nightmare.
And it's in part due to all the different
layers of regulations,
starting with the employers
basically said if you talk to the press
or if you post about it on social media,
you might get fired. And I
think there was a case where
a doctor in Washington State was fired
for basically blabbering
about the shortage.
And then you have the CDC and the WHO
saying, "You know what,
masks are not needed."
This was some rhetoric
that's been circulating
since the crisis started.
And that helps hospitals
kind of CYA, cover your ass,
because if masks are not
needed, then the onus
isn't on them to stock up
and protect the workers.
It basically protects them,
it gives them some liability
if, let's say you die
on the job or something,
then it's harder to sue
because it's not required,
the CDC just said you
don't really need masks.
And then you have compliance issues,
so the FDA, they need
to certify all the masks
for does it do what it says
it does and everything.
But then different
layers of certification,
different agencies have
different standards
and then you have this bidding war,
so all 50 states are
bidding, the feds are bidding
for the same supply pool,
and then you have NGOs
and then you have the global market
and we all just end up
bidding against each other
and just driving the price up.
What should have been done is perhaps
start of with some sort
of all the governors
come together at the start of consortium
and bid against global actors as well
and there's just so much
redundancy (microphone distorts)
this entire market but
it's been so difficult
trying to get PPEs to the hospitals.
And the last
- Yeah, so I know
that lot of my audience hearing this
is gonna go, "Oh yeah, well of course,
"regulation, red tape, this is exactly
"what the government does to get us all
"in a boondoggle where prices drive up,
"nobody can get what they
want and the rest of it."
So is the best way to just
get rid of all the red tape?
How do we then make sure that products
that actually work are
the ones getting to us,
if there's no regulation whatsoever?
I'm slightly playing the devil's advocate.
- Well, there's short-term,
long-term issues.
So one of the stories that came out
was this Brooklyn man
was apparently hoarding,
he had started purchasing
millions of masks
or something and was
hoarding a lot of them.
And we're so concerned about price gouging
that if you're an importer here,
you don't wanna be
guilty of price gouging,
so you don't import the masks
because of the price fluctuations
and the feds are gonna come after you,
as they did after this Brooklyn man,
who basically did nothing wrong
except buy a ton of masks
and hold on to them.
That's his property and they
came and they seized it.
And while this is good intention,
businesses or people shouldn't be trying
to make a profit during a crisis,
the problem is that the
price, when it goes up,
is basically an incentive
for produces to produce.
So we should be letting the
prices fluctuate, right,
because then we can
rush to meet the demand.
And it's one of those
policies or sentiments
that just has unintended consequences.
It sounds good in principle
but it has unintended consequences.
I think the short term is we might need to
be a bit more protectionist.
I think it makes sense
to have export controls,
to prevent our current supply of PPEs
leaving the country,
we should've done that.
But then in the long term,
we have to let the prices,
we have to let the market fluctuate
because it's gonna correct itself.
You know what Facebook did?
Facebook prevented mask advertisements
because they were concerned
about the hoarding issue.
So they basically said, "All right
(microphone distorts) now"
But then if you (microphone distorts)
and you came up with a
way to 3D print a mask,
now you (microphone distorts)
money for a Kickstarter.
So we're really shooting
ourselves in the foot.
- So you mention the WHO, the
World Health Organization,
and the CDC, the Center
for Disease Control.
It seems like in the
last month, the messaging
out of the WHO specifically has been just
absolutely all over the place.
And there's some people that say,
"Oh, well they didn't want
to push people into masks"
sort of for the reasons you're saying
because then regular people
who maybe don't need them
are gonna get all the masks,
the people who need them
won't have access to them.
But have they as an organization
really just kind of flubbed
this thing from the beginning?
- Yeah, absolutely.
There's no question that the WHO
has basically abandoned
its duties in so many ways.
I mean, you can go all
the way back to December.
If you go back to December 30th,
that's when China first
reported to the WHO
that there were these cases,
a cluster of about 41 people,
that was the first time it was reported.
A day later, on the 31st of
January, it was New Year's Eve,
Taiwan basically said to the WHO,
"Hey, we have heard that
this is really serious
"and that's there's
human-to-human transmission."
This was on the 31st of December
and the reason Taiwan knew about this
was because there were Taiwanese doctors
who had heard from their
mainland colleagues
that the medical staff in
Wuhan were getting sick.
So that's how you know human-to-human
transmission is occurring,
it's not animal-to-person
but person-to-person,
the patients are transferring
it to the doctors.
So Taiwan reports this
and it takes weeks before,
I think on the 14th of January,
you still have that
famous tweet by the WHO
saying there's still no evidence
of human-to-human transmission,
two weeks after Taiwan
told them that there was.
And this has been the story
of how they've handled this.
They've Kowtow to China.
- Well let's just pause
there for one sec though,
let's just pause there
for one sec. What is that?
Like what do you think structurally,
as someone that knows about
organizations like this,
what happened in those two weeks?
Were they intentionally misleading us?
Did they just completely drop the ball?
Was there political pressure?
Was it they didn't wanna be too alarmist?
Is it some combination
of all of those thing?
- No, actually, the problem is that Taiwan
doesn't have membership to the WHO.
So China has very successfully
muscled Taiwan out.
So Taiwan's not recognized as a member
and for Taiwan that's very dangerous
because if you don't have that connection
to the WHO, you are not plugged into
this global health alert system.
And the global health alert system
is not plugged into Taiwan.
So whatever intel Taiwan
had was completely missed.
And then the worst part for Taiwan
is that because China
basically muscled them out,
when all the other countries
were placing travel bans,
they were trying to ban people from China
traveling to their countries,
they inadvertently banned Taiwan
because Taiwan was seen as part of China,
which is what China wants.
- Mm-hm, okay, so the WHO drops the ball,
and then we've subsequently seen
some other strange tweets and we've seen
some strange statements by
some of their representatives.
Trump was talking about a ban from China
back in January, right?
- Yeah, he instituted the
ban I think 31st of January,
that's when the ban initially happened.
But, at the time, the WHO was saying
that they shouldn't do it,
that you shouldn't
restrict travel to China.
And shortly after that, also
the Chinese Foreign Ministry,
they reacted very badly to Trump's ban,
saying that it was racist and xenophobic
to institute the ban.
- Yeah, surprise, surprise.
So what do you make of the fact that now,
because hindsight is
20/20, people are saying,
"Oh Trump didn't do anything in February.
"Everyone knew that this was gonna happen.
"Trump didn't do anything."
I checked yesterday and it turns out
that there was a Democratic debate
on February, I think
it's 7th, 19th and 25th,
none of those debates mentioned
anything about coronavirus, oddly,
yet the media is now telling us
that everybody was talking about
all of this stuff in February.
- Oh, no they were not.
- Could he have done more?
Should he have done more?
How do you balance keeping people sane
and keeping the economy open versus
a potential looming threat, all of that.
- I mean he did suggest that
he was somewhat distracted
by the impeachment proceedings
and for the whole month of February,
you did have our journalist
class doing one of two things,
saying that this was just another flu
or warning people that the
stigma against Asian-Americans
was worse than the virus itself.
And so even on the 9th of February,
you had the health
officials in New York City
saying come out for our
Lunar New Year Parade,
everything's okay, life is normal,
stand up to xenophobia and racism.
So they were still acting
as if, understandably,
a lot of people missed this,
it's okay, let's all just party and mix
and stand in defiance to this virus.
So a lot of people missed
it but I read yesterday
that on the 29th of
January that Peter Navarro,
who was the trade official
in Trump's cabinet,
actually wrote a memo warning and saying
that this virus is the real deal
and there's gonna be, at
worst, two million deaths,
at best a hundred thousand
but we gotta act on this.
And he proposed actually a travel ban.
Trump said he didn't read the memo
but shortly after, on the 31st,
he actually did put down the travel ban.
That's one of the good things about Trump,
is that he didn't really care about that
and this virus really fit in well
with his ideological priors for being
conservative on immigration and being
a bit more nationalistic in
terms of trade and engagement.
America first.
- Yeah, can you talk a little bit about
just the inner machinations of China?
Because right now, just
in the last few days,
we've seen this thing where U.S. cases
are spiking but China is
reporting no new cases,
no new deaths, and it's like, all right.
And then NBC News will
literally make that statement.
The AP will make that statement.
And it's like, well I guess
that's sort of reporting,
in that you're reporting
what China's reporting
but that's not really
independent reporting.
Can you talk a little
bit about how information
can or can't travel in China?
- The media's job is to be skeptical
and, towards that end,
they are very skeptical
when it comes to reporting
about the Trump administration
but they're not affording
that same approach
to the Chinese government,
when of all people
who you should be skeptical about,
it should be numbers that are coming
from a very closed authoritarian society.
And I think China has had a history
of covering up numbers in general.
People are very skeptical
about even numbers
coming out from their GDP calculations,
how they miraculously always meet
the exactly 6% quota target, like exact.
So they have a history of hiding things
and the fact that they had no qualms
suppressing the whistleblower,
censoring their social media.
Why would we not assume that
they're covering up their numbers?
- So if we can't trust the numbers
that we're getting out of China,
and, sadly, we can't really trust
our own media to report on it properly
rather than just regurgitate the numbers,
how do we get some sensible
information out of China?
Is there a way to do it
that you can truly trust?
- Well the CIA apparently they submitted
a classified report to the White House,
Bloomberg reported on it,
and they actually basically said that
they were trying to verify China's numbers
and they were unable to.
So apart from intelligence agencies
or using some sort of proxy,
I think a lot of people saw these videos
that were circulated on social media,
all the urns that were
going to funeral homes,
and it didn't seem to match
up with what was reported.
The problem is that a lot of these videos,
once they get posted
by citizen journalists
on the ground in Wuhan,
they end up getting taken down so fast.
So the information out of
China's just unreliable
and, unfortunately, the only
thing that we have to work with
is the numbers they're
submitting to the WHO.
- Yeah, can you talk a little bit more
just generally about our
relationship with China,
China's sort of geopolitical ambitions
and some of the stuff
that they've been doing
that has kind of led us to
this really precarious point?
- Well, China's been on the
ascending for a long time,
ever since Deng Xiaoping
instituted market reforms.
They insist on calling it socialism
with Chinese characteristics
and that's really just a euphemism
for moving it in a more
capitalistic direction
and it's been slowly
liberalizing economically.
And we've engaged with
China since Richard Nixon
went in and built that relationship.
And every president so
far has engaged with them.
We've sort of subscribed to this idea
that the more interconnected
our markets are
and the richer China becomes,
eventually it's going to
liberalize politically as well,
that you'll see freedoms come in.
That the average person in
China who's more affluent
will start demanding to
have freedom of speech
and political freedoms to
vote their leaders out.
And that just hasn't been the case at all.
And, if anything, China's
become far more powerful
than they've been and they're also growing
in their ambitions.
So you can see this with
their military expansions
in the South China Sea, the
Belt and Road Initiative,
which is basically this
infrastructure project
where they sign up all these countries
around the world to build infrastructure
and that becomes what they
call debt-trap diplomacy.
So they're holding them in a way
and using that as their economic clout
as a way to have leverage
on these countries.
So the Chinese system
is really not compatible
with the U.S.'s vision for
the world and also values.
And, I think, it's quite clear
that we're becoming
strategic rivals and that,
in fact, there's a good
argument to be made
also that China is
posing as a very possible
existential threat to the United States.
- So are you saying that
for the two plus years
that we were focused
on Russia and Ukraine,
perhaps we should've
been focused elsewhere
and that our eye was off the ball
because of some other nonsense,
is that what you're getting at?
- Well, you know, one of
Trump's campaign promises
was, he has been talking
about China a lot,
you've seen these clips, like
China, when he does that.
That's just a central
issue to his platform
and he's been talking
about it for a long time,
that we've got a very
bad trade deal with them
and he wants to come in and fix it.
The problem with his rhetoric was that he
sort of talked about it in a sense
of making America strong
again economically,
bringing jobs home, but he didn't frame it
in terms of this geopolitical
struggle, which it is.
Maybe that's because of
the need to still have some
form of relationship in
real politic with China
and that would really offend them.
But all China analysts and people
who have been on the ball on this issue,
have been sounding the alarm for a while.
Look at how they're able to coerce us,
even outside of their own borders,
to basically parrot their orthodoxy
when it comes to the whole
NBA Hong Kong fiasco,
or even what kind of messages
are embedded in movies.
So you can see they've been
trying to influence from afar.
- How dangerous is it that
we owe them a lot of money?
These are our creditors.
I'm pretty sure we're never
gonna pay that money back.
Where does that put us?
- In a very precarious position.
But there are also very strong signs
that the Chinese economy
itself is not very sustainable.
And that there are issues,
that we're just waiting
for this bubble to pop.
So being indebted to
China obviously is giving
us a lot of issues when
it comes to leverage
and it's also a little
bit of an embarrassment
that the world superpower is unable
to have that financial
hold over a trading partner
that's also a strategic rival.
But Trump has actually
ballooned that trait,
our deficit, since he came into office.
And the way this crisis is going to go,
that's just gonna get even
worse with our economy.
- Yeah, and it's not just our economy
and our government
that's in bed with China.
We've got the NBA in bed with China,
we've got universities in bed with China,
giant corporations, so
there's a multilayered
element to this, right?
- (microphone distorts) companies too.
You talked about NBC just now, right.
NBC's parent company, Comcast,
actually had (microphone
distorts) deals in China.
They've invested billions of dollars
to build a Minion Land, this theme park.
I can't think of anything worse.
To me, that is literally hell,
it's being in Minion Land in Beijing.
So they've invested billions
in these theme parks,
Harry Potter Village.
And you can just imagine
what China did to the NBA,
after one general manager said
something about Hong Kong,
where they just canceled
all the screenings
of the NBA in China.
That was how they retaliated
when they didn't like
what one NBA manager tweeted.
Can you imagine the kind of leverage
over media companies,
over Hollywood companies
because they have business
dealings with them?
- What do you make of
the way that everyone
falls into line when it comes to China?
So that NBA thing was pretty amazing
because it was a random general manager,
I think for the Houston Rockets,
or maybe it was even an
assistant general manager,
but a guy that nobody really knew his name
outside of the, yeah,
so he is the general manager.
But nobody really knows his name
outside of the basketball world.
But after that happened,
the amount of NBA players,
Lebron James included, who
all sort of bowed to China,
the same people who will go on and on
and rip America as a racist, evil state
and tell you that Trump is Hitler,
but immediately, all of them,
the entire league, suddenly was bowing.
Steve Kerr is a great example of that,
who runs around saying how awful
Trump is and everything else.
But suddenly, when it came to China,
ooh, gotta shut up and quick.
- Well, the Chinese market is much larger
than the U.S. market for the NBA.
And they've been trying to get
into China for a long time.
So this has been, for them,
just the biggest moneymaker.
Not to mention all the licensing deals,
NBA stores there, shoe
companies and all that.
I would say there's actually one player
that's been pretty good
on this China issue
and that is Enes Kanter, and
that's because he himself
knows what it's like to
live under an authoritarian
and what it's like to stand up to one,
Turkish prime minister.
- Turkish in this case, yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
So it's a shame that market access alone
can really modify our behavior so much,
to the point where these players
who are so quick to support causes.
There was a NBA boycott of North Carolina
because of the bathroom bills
that when it came to
sticking up for our values,
for the right of Americans,
who just have an opinion about Hong Kong,
all of a sudden it just
went out the window.
That's really sad.
- Yeah, by the way, what's
the latest in Hong Kong?
I mean, with everything
going on right now,
we don't hear anything
about Hong Kong anymore.
But, I mean, they were singing
the national anthem on the streets.
- Yeah, yeah, but there's
- American national anthem.
- And they were waving the flags
and also waving the Union Jack.
Well, the coronavirus, obviously,
has rendered all protests impossible.
So, in that sense, it's
really muted that down.
And also, recently, they
had this anti-masking law,
the Chief Executive of Hong Kong,
because they didn't want their protestors
to be able to mask up but now,
because everybody
actually has to wear masks
to protect themselves
against the coronavirus,
they had to rewrite the law.
So that's the last I heard about Hong Kong
but there are no protests going on now.
And it's a shame because it's so moving
to see young people on the streets,
standing up against tyranny,
standing up against authoritarianism.
- What's your sense that
once we get past this thing,
which I assume you
believe we'll get past it,
how some of the nature of the relationship
with China will Change?
Or at least our discussion
about what they're doing?
- I think, in a way, America
has woken up to this.
It shouldn't have taken this.
But we've woken up to the
fact that our industrial
supply chain was located
inside an adversary.
Our medical, lifesaving medical drugs,
all the active ingredients in our drugs
were also made in China.
And just people are starting to see
and wake up to this fact
that there is a clash
in value systems between
the two countries.
And it just couldn't be more clear now.
It should've been clear to us,
what they did with the NBA,
the Hong Kong issue, it
should've been clear then.
But now it's rally hitting us.
And I've seen a lot of
people now express the view,
"You know what, I don't care
about the cheap stuff anymore.
"I'd rather just pay more and be secure
"and have our supply chains
relocated back to America."
Especially when it comes
to the sensitive stuff.
I'm not talking about
making crayons or something,
we're talking about
anything to do with tech,
the higher value items.
- Yeah, so moving away
from China a little bit,
for our remaining time, you're
a pretty astute observer
of what's happening in America too
and I know you've sort of been on your own
political journey over
the last couple of years,
that I think in some ways
is sort of similar to mine,
even though we come, obviously,
from a very a different starting point.
What do you make about what's happening
right now politically in America?
The way the conversation is?
As we're taping this
today, we just found out
that Bernie Sanders is dropping out.
We're holding this for a little bit.
Do you think Biden can even do this?
Where are you at with Trump?
What's your general take,
as the New York editor
of "Spectator" magazine,
which is actually one of
the few places of journalism
that I don't have to
use air quotes around,
which is a really refreshing thing.
- Yeah, well, I'm really excited
that they gave me an opportunity
and they've never tried to muzzle me
or steer me into an ideological track.
It's just write whatever you want,
pitch whatever you want,
and so, in that sense,
I do have a lot of journalistic freedom.
In terms of where America is politically,
this coronavirus issue really
threw a wrench into it.
We were all kind of going along
and all of the sudden, the
news just changed overnight.
Just completely saturated.
And, at this point, it's not even clear
if things are going to get lifted.
I'm hearing conversations now about voting
and whether we're gonna do
this mail voting at some point.
I don't know but, suffice to say,
there is a lot of
dissatisfaction about Joe Biden.
And I wrote a piece for
"Spectator" about how
I don't think the media
actually vetted him properly.
I don't think they put
him through the gauntlet
in a way that they did do
to every other candidate.
If you looked at Pete
Buttigieg, Bloomberg,
even Andrew Yang, you
would find a hit piece
on "The New York Times" about how they
were either racist in
their past or sexist,
except maybe Pete Buttigieg.
But there's something there.
And Biden just wasn't put
through the same pressures.
And so he's emerged and
now the big question
is about his mental
state, does he have the,
not just temperament but is he sane enough
to actually be the president
of the United States.
And what he's coming up against Trump,
the optics, it's gonna look so bad.
But the issue is, at the end of the day,
the math just didn't work out for Bernie.
I know a lot of people liked him.
I mean, your and my friend now, I guess,
Joe Rogan really liked Bernie too.
But I see a lot of people
kind of echoing what he said,
which is "Bernie or bust" on the left.
And it's creating such a big rift.
I don't know how that's
gonna get resolved.
- Yeah, so as someone
that's now in the media,
what do you make of the media these days?
Because I'm sort of like, man.
You know, a lot of us have
been screaming about the media
for a while and I think
maybe now that so many people
are trapped at home and
they're forced online more,
I think it's becoming
more and more obvious
to people that maybe weren't
taking the temperature.
So that if you were watching CNN
with their selectively edited Trump quotes
and normally you wouldn't pay
that much attention to it,
now you're stuck at home online
and you're seeing full quotes be shared
by other people where
they stop his sentence
right after he says but
this da-da-da-da-dah.
Do you sense that the media
has just gone completely crazy?
Is there a way to get them to come back?
I mean can "The New York
Times" reel it back in?
Can CNN reel it back in?
Or have they just chosen a
model that they think is best,
which is, well, I guess, lie,
because that's what your base wants?
Something like that?
- Well, I saw that CBS was
using video clips of Italy
when they were talking
about the New York situation
and that is just gaslighting.
- Italian hospitals, they were literally
showing Italian hospitals.
- It does erode the public trust.
I mean, I think we have to separate
between the opinion pieces
and the actual reporting.
The International Bureau
of these big organizations,
like "The New York Times",
they do excellent reporting
when it comes to the Middle East,
I mean, even on China,
which recently expelled
"Wall Street Journal", "Washington Post"
and "The New York Times" journalists
that were there for decades,
expelled out of Beijing.
And now we don't have eyes on them there.
They have opinion pieces
and activist journalists,
that's really where I
think the problem is.
And, apart from just the
business model issue,
which I think we haven't
really solved yet.
You've actually kind of
built a platform to solve it.
But that is one of the
reasons why this world
of activism journalism exists.
It's click baity and the incentives
that reward that kind of
journalism is still there.
I don't know how to solve this.
It's just, apart from changing this
and rewiring the whole
incentive structure,
or just having what we do have now,
this fragmentation of media,
is actually probably a good thing.
I know we used to say
that it was a bad thing.
But the fact that there
is conservative media,
I mean, frankly, Tucker Carlson,
I'm so impressed with him.
The coverage that he has done
since this coronavirus started.
And actually before that,
he was doing really good
stuff also on China.
But it's important more
than ever that we do
have these voices because
it puts the pressure.
I had a tweet about this the other day.
So there was a clip where
a Hong Kong journalist,
interviewed someone from the
WHO, a very senior official,
and asked him about Taiwan
and he just backtracked.
It was such a shameful, tried to weasel
out of the conversation
and it looked really bad.
And for the first four hours,
the only media that reported on it
was the Blaze, was Fox News, was PJ Media,
was all the so-called right wing.
But if it didn't get picked up by them,
the story would've never bubbled up.
And by picking up on it, they were forcing
the mainstream media to
respond, to log that,
and it kind of gets into
the public consciousness
in a way that, imagine
if they didn't exist,
it just wouldn't have.
So it is important that
we have competing interest
and at least there's a chance
that the truth gets out.
- Yeah and I know for
you, as I think someone
that you still consider
yourself a good, decent Liberal,
it's kinda funny that
you have all these allies
on the right and you have to give props
to conservative media, I suppose,
to get these stories out there.
Unfortunately, we don't have
anymore time but quickly
in 30 seconds, and then next time
we're obviously gonna do this in person
and it will be great to see you again.
Just give me your sense
of when we get out of this
and are we gonna be okay on
the other side of this thing?
- I think we're gonna have
to learn how to live with it,
as long as there is no vaccine,
as long as whatever antiviral treatments
are still not developed,
we're gonna have to learn
how to live with the virus
and there's gonna be ways.
So we're in mitigation stage now
and I hope our curves start to flatten.
California's doing a
very good job with it.
So we'll see, but things are realigning
and lives are changing.
- All right, Melissa,
it was great seeing you,
even though we had to do this
through the Skype machine.
We will do this in person next time
and good seeing you, as always.
Hey, everyone, we're obviously
in some unchartered territory
with coronavirus and our plan here
is to help you make as
much sense of the situation
in as non-alarmist fashion as possible.
If you're looking for reliable information
from experts on the front
lines of the pandemic,
check out our coronavirus playlist,
which we'll keep adding
updates to, right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe.